[Music]
in
india 28 of india's population did not
have access to a doctor
on the poor side in the rural areas in
the underserved areas in the remote
areas clearly there is a challenge
that healthcare doctors are not
available facilities may not be
available
and people may have less money so
doctors migrate and go and start working
and practicing in larger and larger
hospitals in bigger cities
[Music]
so that was the reason that we said
let's try and see that
we can create a better model than
between the private and the public
something which can meet the clinical
outcomes
as well as being affordable for people
i belong to you know a typical
middle middle class family from a small
town in india
and you know the aspirations of parents
in those small towns always was
that you have two kids one should be a
doctor one should be an engineer
there was an expectation that i become a
doctor so i became a doctor
my heart is in the villages the small
town places where i come from
and how we can transform those and by
2006
i decided to become an entrepreneur the
other
catalyst was that i lost my father to an
unnecessary surgery in a
very expensive big hospital
and then you realize that the problem is
not just for the
poor and the underserved the problem of
healthcare healthcare being broken is
almost everywhere
now we expect a human doctor to
study so much and so hard that he will
remember everything
in his mind and he will be able to take
the right decision or he'll know the
right question to ask every time
[Music]
that is impossible therefore what you
need actually
is that you need to rethink how we are
delivering healthcare
and that is the reason that you need to
innovate and find a better solution
dr zim founded glocal healthcare in 2010
after realizing there was a rural
healthcare gap that needed to be filled
but in order to be sustainable from a
business perspective
it needed to have a low overhead and be
incredibly efficient
his answer technology
so how do you ensure that everybody gets
health care across the world so here
comes in telemedicine
so today's technology allows you to do
rich video
between a doctor and a patient and
connect them like an
uber across where patients might be and
doctors might be that's step one
step two is medical data is huge
it is vast so we built a clinical
decision support system
that basically ensures that doctors are
able to do better diagnosis
that drug interactions dosages
contraindications drug interactions
everything
is actually sorted out and doctors can
focus on the patient rather than trying
to think through the data
the third is now i need to be able to
examine the patient
and i may be sitting far away i may be
sitting in new york for that matter or
bangalore for that pattern a patient may
be an orisa
so internet of things today allows you
to get
data and transmit it across
there's a digital stethoscope there is
in digital ecg
otoscope rhinoscope laryngoscope
thermoscope fetal doppler
finally the pharmacy the pharmacy is
inbuilt in technology
automated so that it delivers there's no
physical doctor present there it's only
a nurse
which is present there who runs you
through the whole system
you are able to do your consultation
investigation examination medication not
just checkup
you're doing the entire primary health
care in one go in less than 30 minutes
so what we have done is we have taken
consultation lab and a pharmacy the
clinic pharmacy and lab
put them back together into one single
hole which primary care actually
should be bring down the cost that
both in terms of money and time and
remove medical errors by using
artificial intelligence
so this by this what we have done is
we've solved the problem of how to
deliver primary health care
not just in urban areas rural areas
islands remote areas
the one which we have innovated very
recently which is what we call hello
life cx is a brand name that we've given
to it
which is absolutely small it's like 64
square foot eight feet by eight feet
which can be installed anywhere
a general primary consultation along
with medication
and investigation the whole thing we are
doing for as low as four dollars
for four dollars you get a doctor tests
and your medicines
which is less than 300 rupees in india
is the cheapest the most affordable
primary healthcare system that we are
aware of
the mini clinics like the one here
called hello life cx
cost around 25 000 us dollars to build
and can be set up in under a day
glocal has 240 of them around india
as well as 11 larger hospitals with
emergency services in rural areas
including the app the company is one of
the largest telemedicine operators in
the world
the biggest problems of the poor
of the marginalized of remote areas
okay will not be solved by poor
technology
but to be able to deliver healthcare in
three dollars or five dollars
your technology has to be absolutely
phenomenal
that can squeeze out the maximum amount
of data
the decision making the ability to
deliver everything has to be so
productive and so efficient that you are
able to create a sustainable margin
within that five dollars
so to solve the problem with the poor
it's a bad thing to do
when you think of putting in a cheap
thing
you have to be able to put the most
expensive
piece of technology which can create so
much of productivity
that the product itself can be cheaper
in the hands of the person
there are 7.8 billion people on this
planet
it was becoming inevitable that
technologies will have to provide a
solution that whatever can be done
without the doctor having to travel or
the patient having to travel
i think this pandemic has only catalyzed
this movement
[Music]
certainly in india and in a lot of asian
african countries
when people are poor and the money is
less healthcare
is sought only for the wage earner
because this guy is earning he's earning
member of the family if he falls ill
they will seek healthcare
but for the old for the women and the
children they would be neglected
and we are seeing and this is probably
the most gratifying thing that you see
that almost 50 percent of the patients
are women which it should be because you
are 50 50 in the population
so which means that it has increased the
equity in the society
the justice in the society so healthcare
access is no longer limited to wage
earner
or the upper caste or the privileged
members or the richer members of the
society but everybody
it is coming in faster it is bringing
the cost down so reducing poverty and
the biggest thing is that is available
everywhere
you